president Trump tests out his 20/20
message in a crucial North Carolina's
special election bellwether Democrats
hone in on front but trip over
themselves and Google is in everybody's
crosshairs I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
well today is a big election in North
Carolina's ninth congressional district
now why do special elections like this
matter well typically people say that
they are a bellwether a bellwether we're
gonna find out whether this is a
microcosm of the American electorate at
large and very often these cases don't
end up actually being bellwethers we saw
a few of them in the last election cycle
people thought that what happened in
Georgia that a congressional special
election John aasif narrowly lost that
seat we saw a couple of other very
narrow congressional elections in
special election districts and people
saw it on the right as a bellwether for
Trump and on the left is about whether
anti-trump we saw this in 2011 as well
in the lead in the lean up to 2020 in
the lead up to 2012 there were a couple
of special elections one was in New York
City Anthony Weiner lost his seat he was
replaced by a Republican Bob Turner in
Nevada there was a special election
where a Republican replaced a Democrat
and Republicans sort of convinced
themselves that that was indicative of a
wave a Republican wave in 2012 well the
Republican wave never arrived in 2012 it
sort of crashed several miles offshore
Democrats are seeing the same
possibility in North Carolina so it's
easy to over-read the effect of these
sort of special elections a year and a
half out we don't even have a Democratic
nominee for president as of yet however
it is indicative of at least a warning
sign for Republicans if Democrats were
to win this North Carolina district
tonight why well because this particular
district was won by President Trump not
by two points not by four points not by
eight this is 1 by 12 points in the last
election cycle last presidential
election cycle for President Trump and
right now it is a neck-and-neck race
between a conservative state senator
named Dan Bishop
it's a vacancy and a Democrat named Dan
McReady who's a former Marine who earned
a Harvard master's degree in business
and narrowly trailed in an election for
the seat last year that was later
invalidated after evidence surfaced of
election fraud you remember that there
was a big controversy over this
particular seat specifically because of
allegations of election fraud so that
obviously does have an impact on how the
voting goes in this seat because in all
likelihood if it had not been for the
election fraud Dan McCrory you might
have filled the seat already so this
does have a little bit of baggage
attached to it it's not a clean
bellwether it's not a clean
indicator of what's gonna happen come
2020 it's particularly not crank clean
also because McCready happens to be
politically moderate for a Democrat
she's more of a Blue Dog Democrat than
he is an AOC type or a Bernie Sanders
type or an Elizabeth Warren type so
using a moderate Democrat in a red
district that is plagued by allegations
of election corruption as a stand-in for
2020 isn't easy over it with that said
obviously people are watching this
because if the Republican were to blow
out the Democrat then that would suggest
that maybe they're a bunch of secret
Republican voters who aren't reporting
themselves to pollsters if Democrats
were to win the seat that's obviously a
serious siren for Republicans this is a
heavily suburban North Carolina seat
that went heavy red for Trump in 2016 so
district stretches from Charlotte
according to the AP one of the nation's
financial nerve centers through its
flourishing eastern suburbs and into the
less prosperous rural counties along the
south carolina line with next summer's
RNC convention in Charlotte Democrats
would love to boast control of a
congressional district in the city where
Trump will be renowned nated over half
the district's votes will likely come
from Charlotte suburbs those suburbs are
of course the real trouble spot for
president Trump come 2020 in Texas we've
been seeing as the suburbs have been
turning purple scaring state leaders in
that state as well Democrats captured 39
GOP held seats last November took
control of the house many of their
pickups were in suburbs even in states
like Texas Kansas Utah South Carolina
and Oklahoma so President Trump now had
to descend into this district to push
his message and so this will be one of
the questions as well is it actually a
benefit or a drawback when Trump shows
up in suburbia in order to stump for
Republican candidates now Trump has sort
of dictated in the past that he wants to
show up in particular districts in
particular areas and Republicans have
been extremely torn on this I mean I've
spoken with many many Republican
Congress people who simply are not sure
whether it is benefit or a detriment if
Trump shows up in their districts just
prior to an election he's a deeply
polarizing figure he does get out the
base he also gets out the other guys
base well president Trump now has to
descend into a district he won by 12 my
Pence is also showing up in that
district that Trump won by 12 and
President Trump launched into his 2020
stump speech now this was the best of
Trump
this was the greatest hits of Trump and
this is really what his campaign should
look like because nearly his entire
campaign speech was directed against
Democrats he touted his own record
particularly on employment and on his
wanting to build a wall but overall it
was a it was a brutal attack on
Democrats and if he sticks to this for a
year and a half then he has a very solid
shot at re-election if however he gets
distracted by a myriad of silliness then
obviously his chances go down so
President Trump leads off his rally last
night with an optimistic message the
best days are yet to come we are one
movement one people one family and one
glorious nation under God America is
thriving like never before we may have
right now the greatest economy in the
history of our nation and ladies and
gentlemen of North Carolina the best is
yet to come okay so this is not B
message obviously and it's gonna get out
the bass is gonna reach out to
independence who knows
okay president Trump then follows that
up by touting low unemployment which of
course is his chief pitch and the
unemployment rate is extraordinarily low
there's a report out today that suggests
that not only is the unemployment rate
low according to the Washington Post for
the first time most new working age
hires in the United States are people of
color he the Washington Post is now
reporting that the that women are
predominantly driving the trend they say
the surge of minority women getting jobs
has helped push the United States
workforce across a historic threshold
for the first time most new hires of
prime working age 25 to 54 are people of
color
minority hires overtook white hires last
year which suggests that there are a lot
of people and minority communities who
are now getting jobs who wouldn't have
had jobs if it were not for president
Trump's economy if you can in tribute
the economy to a presidential figure a
question of which I am somewhat doubtful
minority women began to pour into the
labor market in 2015 they've begun to
reshape the demographics of the US
workforce especially because many white
baby boomers have been retiring their
5.2 million more people in the United
States with jobs and at the end of 2016
and 4.5 million of them are minorities
according to the post analysis of Labor
Department data ok so that should be
good news
for president from going forward to 2020
here he is touting low unemployment
nearly 600,000 Americans entered the
labor force last month alone think about
now you have the best unemployment
numbers employment and unemployment
numbers that you've ever had as African
Americans as Asian Americans as Hispanic
Americans the best numbers we've ever
had
and by the way African American youth
unemployment has also reached the lowest
level ever recorded in history obviously
that is gonna have to be his pitch if
the economy sinks at all then he is in
trouble now Trump himself is already
saying that this particular district is
quote not a bellwether he says I don't
see it as a bellwether that that's never
a great sign when you're already
downplaying the effects of a particular
district as the president with that said
he's correct it's not a complete
bellwether but it does say something now
in a second we're gonna get to the other
half of Trump's message part of his
message is here's all the good stuff
I've done and then the more damaging
part of his message for Democrats is
here's what they want and again if he
focuses like a laser beam out in on this
message then he's more likely to see
success come 2020 we'll get into that in
just one second first let's talk about
the second amendment Democrats have
basically said at this point they're
coming for your guns beta O'Rourke says
that he wants to come for all of your
weapons right he would like a gun
buyback program for all quote unquote
assault weapons you know that that is
only the first step for him going after
semiautomatic weapons as well handguns
well the founders knew that there were
going to be a lot of people at the top
of our government who were interested in
removing our ability to protect
ourselves and that's why when the
founders crafted the Constitution the
first thing they did was to ensure
freedom of speech and the second thing
they did was ensure that that right
remained free by preventing the
government from encroaching on that
right and other rights with the Second
Amendment I'm a gun owner because I care
about that I'm a gun owner because I
care about my own personal safety owning
a rifle is an awesome responsibility
building rifles is no different started
in a garage by Marine veteran more than
two decades ago bravo company
manufacturing BCM for short builds a
professional-grade product built to
combat standards bravo company
manufacturing is not a sporting arms
company they designed the engineer they
manufacture life-saving
equipment which is the stuff I care
about so I'm not a big hunter to learn
more about Bravo company manufacturing
head on over to Bravo Company MFG commie
can discover more about their product
special offers upcoming news that's
Bravo Company MFG comm if you need more
convincing check them out over at
YouTube as well youtube.com slash Bravo
Company USA that's youtube.com slash
Bravo Company USA amazing people making
terrific weapons to protect yourself and
protect your freedoms that's Bravo
Company MFG comm okay so president
Trump's other message on the campaign
stump is that Democrats would like to
sink the economy right his economy is
really good Democrats are pushing
policies that will sink the economy
again this happens to be true for all of
these crazy people but then that's how
crazy they know what they're doing they
talk about Russia Russia Russia Russia's
not too happy about that their primary
source of income is oil and gas and now
we're bigger than Russia bigger than
Saudi Arabia we're bigger than everybody
yet every leading Democrat running for
president pledges to ban the energy that
drives our economy and wage and under if
you look at what's going on your way of
life is under assault by these people ok
this is all true it's all true and this
is why the Democrats doing a seven-hour
town hall on climate change in which
they pledge to ban everything up to and
including the type of underwear you wear
that turns out not to have been a great
pitch the Democrats are giving Trump
plenty of material to work with he has
to not give that material to work with
Trump says Democrats wants to destroy
the American Dream again this is all
part of his picture now the way the
media pledged this it's amazing I love
the media coverage the media pitched
this the AP has a story about Trump
delivering a dark speech at arks they've
been trying this routine since 2015 he
keeps talking about a dark vision of
America no that's called politics ok
Barack Obama suggested that if
Republicans were to win control of the
White House in 2012 they would return
America back to the 1950s
so yes the way you do politics is by
pointing out what you think America will
look like if your opponents win here is
Trump doing just that last night in
Fayetteville North Carolina for years
you watched as your politicians
apologize for America now you have a
president who is standing up for America
we are standing up for the people of
North Carolina a vote for any Democrat
in 2020 and a vote for any Democrat
tomorrow in North Carolina is a vote for
the rise of radical socialism and the
destruction of the American dream
okay that pitch becomes easier by the
way if Elizabeth Warren is the nominee
as opposed to somebody like Joe Biden
Trump also is appealing to the forces of
anti-global ISM when I say globalism I
don't mean any sort of coded language I
mean the idea of transnational
governance President Trump is very much
opposed to the idea that the Europeans
and their public sentiment should decide
the future of the United States he's
pointing out that Democrats keep saying
he's unpopular in Europe he's like right
that's kind of my pitch we were
defending many countries that treat us
very badly on traded very unfairly we
were defending them and now it's
changing around 100 billion dollars
they're not happy and then I read where
Obama is more popular in Germany than
Trump he's got to be I'm making people
pay their bills he's got to be you know
the day that I'm more popular than him
I'm not doing my job okay I think a lot
of Americans agree with this a lot of
Americans do agree with President Trump
also talking about immigration so this
is his pitch right his pitch is that
Democrats have policies that are outside
the mainstream that he is much more
inside the mainstream that we're not
gonna have our policies decided by the
Europeans again I think all of this is
good stuff Trump was more disciplined
last night than I've seen him in a very
long time here's President Trump talking
about erecting a wall along the southern
border a wall Democrats have opposed you
look at what's happening with human
trafficking and it's mostly women they
traffic in women and they pour through
our borders well every inch of wall that
we put up his vital and were putting up
miles and miles and we can by next year
at the end of the year to have anywhere
between 400 and 500 miles of wall built
and this is serious wall this is the
real deal
okay and he does have the funding to
make that happen so again this is
Trump's 2020 pitch now the question is
going to be in the congressional
district where he is doing this does
this benefit the candidate or does it
not benefit the candidate bishop so the
candidate himself got up and spoke the
problem is that Trump is Trump and
nobody else is from a having Trump
come in and do basically a presidential
rally in your hometown the rally is
going to be about Trump it is not going
to be about you it's not going to be
about transferring the power of the
presidency over to Bishop instead it's
going to be Bishop trying to imitate
Trump and puff Trump up so it'll be
really I have no idea I don't think
anybody has any idea the polls are too
close right now what exactly is going to
happen in this particular district but
here there is a problem for Republicans
and the problem is that again Trump is
very polarizing and the bigger problem
is when you try to beat Trump you fail
no one can beat Trump only Trump can be
Trump there's this sort of let Manny be
Manny yeah it's a baseball-reference
about Manny ramírez this baseball player
for the Cleveland Indians and the Boston
Red Sox and the Los Angeles Dodgers
Manny Ramirez was an incredibly talented
hitter he was also a kook and the rule
about Manny Ramirez was if he hits 330
he gets to be a kook ok but if he starts
hitting 270 then the kookiness ain't
quite so charming well the problem for
Republicans is that let Trump be Trump
only works when you're Trump when you go
from nowhere presidency of the United
States you get to be his kooky as you
want to be but when you are running for
Congress in a local district and you try
to be Trump it isn't gonna work I mean I
don't know like if I were doing optics
for the candidate having the candidate
get up there in the same tie suit combo
it's just not it's not particularly
smart I mean again that is like you're
in the movie with Brad Pitt and you're
an extra and now you've got a line and
you're dressed exactly the same as Brad
Pitt like how exactly is that
particularly smart yeah here is Dan
bishop the the candidate in North
Carolina
now basically stumping for Trump so this
turned into a rally about Trump and from
Sego as opposed to a rally about Bishop
and the necessity for Bishop to be
elected to Congress we've all watched as
the Democratic Party the socialist
Democrat Party
[Applause]
seeks the president's destruction every
day we've seen a dishonest media
[Applause]
serve as their handmaidens and their
allies in that mission okay so going
full Trump in the presence of Trump bold
move cotton we'll see how it works out
for him again with all the caveats it's
not a full-bottle bellwether but it's at
least a part bellwether you lose it you
lose a district in an open seat or Trump
won by 12 just a few years ago the
sirens should be sounding and there
should be a bit of alarm now the way the
Democrats are attempting to run the 2020
election is they are directing just this
Trump is directing his fire at the
Democrats in their radical agenda they
are directing their fire at supposed
scandals but the problem is that Trump
is is a candidate who is vulnerable
because of who he is
instead Democrats seem to be directing
their fire at some of the silliest
aspects of the Trump administration and
then missing whether they're the gang
who can't shoot straight we'll get to
that in just one second first after you
buy a home one of the first things you
need to do is get home insurance
actually legally you have to do that but
getting home insurance it doesn't
actually need to be all that difficult
just like with life insurance or auto
insurance policy genius makes it happen
for you the insurance experts of policy
genius don't think that getting home
insurance needs to be tough that's why
they reimagined the entire process you
can start by answering a few quick
questions so the team can get to know
you and your property then policy genius
does all the hard work to find you the
best home insurance coverage at the best
possible price with policy genius you
get finalized quotes not estimates which
is pretty awesome their team of experts
will help you compare your options
side-by-side so you know exactly what
the heck it is you're looking at if you
already have coverage the policy genius
team will shop your policy around if
there's a better rate out there they'll
do all the heavy lifting and get you
switched plus clients who bundle home
and auto insurance through policy genius
they typically save an additional 20% on
their home insurance policy which is a
lot of money because home insurance is
expensive whether you need home
insurance for a new place or you just
want to reshape your current policy head
on over to policy genius.com
today you can get started on your
smartphone right now that's policy
genius the easy way to compare it and
buy home insurance in the democrats case
when it comes to President Trump is that
he is scandal written out this is a very
bizarre angle that they've been using on
Trump right instead of focusing in on
the fact that Trump is kooky and says
kooky things and is alienating instead
of that they're focusing in
on minor scandals and attempting to blow
them up now Trump can play into their
hands by by doubling down on the
silliness but Democrats are focusing in
on minor things in a way that is that is
pretty astonishing I know this because
Republicans tried to focus in on minor
things in 2011 in the run-up to 2012 and
it didn't work out well the Americans
have a generalized perception of a
candidate and that generalized
perception is what they carry into the
voting booth the best way to undermine a
candidate is to undermine the general
perception of the candidate if that
perception is positive if however the
perception is negative then you
emphasize that you emphasize it each and
every day the way you do that is not by
focusing in on minutiae where most
Americans don't care because then you
seem petty and right now the Democrats
are seeming pretty petty and by the way
they're blowing some of their hits as
well I have to point out so in a second
we'll get to the the discussion of
sharpy gate which continues apace but
there was an attempted hit yesterday on
President Trump that was just botched
completely there's a report from CNN and
the report from CNN was basically the
CIA had to extract an asset in Russia a
high-ranking asset and Russia who was
passing intelligence on to the American
government they had to do it because
Trump was loose-lipped with the Russians
right that's what CNN was attempting to
report but as it turns out that's not
the whole story the New York Times
reports quote decades ago the CIA
recruited and carefully cultivated a
mid-level Russian official who began
rapidly advancing through the government
ranks eventually American spies struck
gold the longtime source landed an
influential position that came with
access to the highest level of the
Kremlin as American officials began to
realize that Russia was trying to
sabotage the 2016 presidential election
The Informant became one of the CIA's
most important and highly protected
assets but when intelligence officials
revealed the severity of Russia's
election interference with unusual
detail later that year the news media
picked up on details about the CIA's
Kremlin sources CIA officials worried
about safety made the arduous decision
in late 2016 to offer the extra to offer
to extract the source from Russia Casey
the original CNN story suggested that it
was President Trump in a meeting with
the Russians who spilled the presence of
the CIA asset requiring the asset to be
withdrawn so is all about Trump but then
the New York Times has a follow-on story
it turns out wasn't about Trump at all
in 2016
see I was already attempting to remove
this source from Russia why because of
the news media because the news media
was already reporting on this guy the
situation according to the New York
Times grew more tense when the
informants had first refused citing
family concerns prompting consternation
at CIA headquarters and sowing doubts
among some American counterintelligence
officials about the informants
trustworthiness but the CIA pressed
again months later after more media
enquiries this time the informant agreed
the move brought to an end the career of
one of the CIA's most important sources
it also effectively blinded American
intelligence officials to the view from
inside Russia as they saw clues about
Kremlin interference in the 2018 midterm
elections and next year's presidential
contest contest CNN first reported the
2017 extraction on Monday other details
including the sources history with the
agency the initial 2016 exfiltration
offer the cascade of doubts
set off by the informants subsequent
refusal have not been previously
reported ok so again as I say the
original report was that the u.s.
extracted a top spy from inside Russia
in 2017 that the report was from Jim
Chiodo over at CNN and it featured a
picture of Donald Trump standing next to
Vladimir Putin Han CNN originally
reported quote a person directly
involved in the discussions said that
the removal of the Russian was driven in
part by concerns that Donald Trump in
his administration repeatedly mishandled
classified intelligence and could
contribute to exposing the covert
sources of spy and the media jumped all
over this yesterday the big media story
on CNN and elsewhere yesterday was that
Trump was indeed basically a Putin plant
and that the United States and his
intelligence resources had to remove a
high-ranking asset in Russia because
Trump couldn't keep his mouth shut with
the Russians but within hours the New
York Times had basically debunked all of
that the New York Times had run a full
story about the real reason this guy was
withdrawn and it was because of news
coverage of the actual informant and
then just to prove the point
NBC News decided that they were going to
demonstrate full-scale how the media
take care for our national security
secrets they ran a piece NBC News did
called possible Russian spy for CIA now
living in Washington area which is
always a great idea as a media outlet in
the United States what you really want
to do is out spies
against the Russians because if we know
one thing about Vladimir Putin it's that
he's a very forgiving and kind man who
never goes after people who are his
enemies and then has them poisoned with
polonium or anything
according to Kendall a nyan and Tatiana
Czestochowa a former senior Russian
official is living in the Washington
area under US government protection
current and former government officials
tell NBC News NBC News is withholding
the man's name and other key details at
the request of US officials who say
reporting the information could endanger
his life yet the former Russian official
who had a job with access to secrets was
living openly under his true name an NBC
News correspondent went to the man's
house in the Washington area and rang
the doorbell
five minutes later two young men in an
SUV came racing up the street and parked
immediately adjacent to the
correspondents car yeah I'm gonna go
with the the New York Times story here
that maybe it was the media treatment of
this particular spy that had the guy
withdrawn from Russia not Trump didn't
matter the media ran with it yesterday
and that was not the only overblown
story yesterday in a second we are going
to get to the continuing saga of the
National Oceanographic and Atmospheric
Administration inside the Trump
administration was idiocy pursued yes is
the is the overblown nature of the
response overblown yeah just a little
bit we'll get to that in just one second
okay there are lots of different types
of cars on the road you know that's
right you're Ivan right have you ever
thought about what happens if one of
those cars it breaks down where exactly
do they get the parts because it's not
easy to just go to the local parts store
and then figure do they have a cart for
this apart for this exotic type of car
instead people should be using the
interwebs I know it's an amazing thing
the interwebs you can get pretty much
anything in if you're looking for auto
parts the best place to go is Rock Auto
comm rockauto.com is a family business
they serve Auto Parts customers online
for 20 years go to rockauto.com shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they've got everything
from engine control modules and brake
parts to tail lamps motor oil even new
carpet whether it's for your classic or
daily driver get everything you need and
a few easy clicks delivered directly to
your door
The Rock auto comm catalog is supremely
easy to navigate you can quickly see all
the parts available for your vehicle and
filter it by brands specifications and
prices best of all the price is over at
rockauto.com are always reliably low and
the
for professionals and do-it-yourselfers
they've got amazing selection reliably
low prices all the parts your car will
ever need go check them out at Rock Auto
dot-com and when you go to rock Auto
calm and see all the parts available for
the car trunk make sure to write shapiro
and then how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you helps us
helps them go check them out right now
at Rock Auto calm and get the best parts
for your auto instead of going over to
the local auto parts shop where you're
gonna get a second-rate part at a
top-notch price get the best possible
price on the best possible part Rock
Auto calm go check them out right now
okay so meanwhile as I say the democrats
members of the media they're going after
that they're grasping at straws with
regard to president Trump but one of the
things that obviously harms President
Trump is when he doubles down on
foolishness and silliness and this has
been the case apparently with the NOAA
now is this gonna break Trump does
anybody really care that President Trump
took a sharpie and marked up a map is
that is that gonna be a thing that they
deeply care about Wow like people going
to the ballot box you know I was gonna
vote for that I was gonna vote for Trump
and then that dude you know any dude he
took a sharpie and marked up a map and
now I'm not voting for him anymore
but Trump is Trump everybody knows that
he's Trump does that mean it's helpful
to Trump to emphasize the Trump enos now
there's something that I say to two
young people who are looking today and
that is you should be yourself
gradually right when you are when you're
first dating you don't want to let out
all your crazy at once right everybody's
crazy and everybody's got their foibles
and everybody's got their weirdnesses on
the first date is not when you explain
to somebody about your Star Wars
obsession it way to like the third date
for that until the person realizes that
you're not just some nutjob all right
then you can start talking about all the
weird stuff about you well in politics
is not that you're hiding who you are
everybody knows who president Trump is
but bringing yourself front of mind with
kooky behavior is not exactly what you
are looking for that's why the NOAA
story is not good for Trump now as well
see people are still over playing it and
turning it into the biggest deal in the
world but is it a great story for Trump
no of course it is not so according to
the Washington Post the head of the
National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration said in an email to
colleagues on Sunday he is investigating
whether the agency's response to
president Trump's Hurricane Dorian
tweets constituted a violation of NOAA
policies and ethics also on Monday the
director
the National Weather Service broke with
NOAA leadership over its handling of
Trump's durian tweets and statements
able to recall late August there were
forecasts from the NOAA that hurricane
torreón was going to strike parts of
Alabama or that it could affect parts of
Alabama a few days later President Trump
started talking about that and then on
September 4th like a full week after
that report when it had basically been
debunked at that point he then went out
and did a full press conference where he
drew with a sharpie
on a map showing exactly where he
thought the hurricane was going to hit
and the NOAA the National Weather
Service first issued a tweet saying that
that wasn't true that the hurricane was
not going to actually hit Alabama it was
instead going to turn north and then the
NOAA basically backed off that
assessment and then the NOAA said well
you know it's true that originally it
was going to hit Alabama and all of this
well now there's an internal
investigation going on at the National
Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration
in an email to NOAA staff obtained by
The Washington Post NOAA is Craig McLean
called the agency's response political
and a danger to public health and safety
Trump's incorrect assertion on September
1st that Alabama would quote most likely
be hit much harder than anticipated set
off a chain of confusion and outrage
among the public and within NOAA at the
time the NWS is forecast guidance showed
only a very small risk about 5% of
tropical storm-force winds for a small
portion of Alabama
however Alabama was not in the storm
forecast track or cone of uncertainty
from the National Hurricane Center that
showed hurricane torian's skirting the
East Coast far away from Alabama
the NWS is Birmingham off has set the
record straight
they said Alabama would not see any
impacts from the storm NOAA officials
then caused an internal uproar on
September 6th when the agency issued an
unsigned statement that defended Trump's
false claim about Alabama and admonished
The Weather Service's Birmingham
division for speaking in absolute terms
acting NOAA administrator Neil Jacobs
and NOAA communications director Julie K
Roberts were involved in drafting
Friday's statement NOAA and NWS had also
appeared to try to correct the record
without angering the president according
to emails obtained by the post before
the statement on Friday
NOAA staff were instructed to quote only
stick with official National Hurricane
Center forecast if questions arise from
some national level social media posts
which hit the news this afternoon and
not
to provide any opinion in response to
president Trump's initial Alabama tweets
then there's a report from the New York
Times overnight that suggested that
Wilbur Ross the head of the Commerce
Department the Secretary of Commerce
that he threatened to fire top employees
at the federal scientific agency
responsible for weather forecasts last
Friday after the agency's Birmingham
office contradicted Trump so none of
that is a particularly good look for
Trump now does that mean that Democrats
are responding to this relatively minor
scandal with the appropriate amount of
caution or with the appropriate amount
of ire no not so much not so much here's
representative Steve Cohen from
Tennessee suggesting that President
Trump is like OJ Simpson you know the
Sharpie thing is amazing Steve when they
asked him at his press conference about
who did it and he escaped the same look
that he had when he was on the airplane
and said he didn't know anything about
paying off stormy Daniels anything about
checks it was that same you know don't
win the headlights look of I'll have no
idea who did it he never did say but I'm
gonna find out who did it he's done
about as much to find out who did that
Sharpie thing as OJ Simpson's done to
find out the murderers yeah it's just
like it's it's like yeah sure
now you're not over blowing this at all
guys it was a sharpie
he took a sharpie and he drawn a map
like I get it it's bad it is it's bad
okay the President of the United States
should not be altering scientific
forecasts to meet his weird perception
of where a a hurricane was going to
travel and members of the administration
should stop going out of their way to
protect president Trump's apparently
fragile ego it's stupid it's a waste of
time and undercuts Trump's pitch which
is that he is the strongest man in the
room
Trump's really the strongest man in the
room then he can take the critique of by
the way you're not correct about that
hurricane and what we've seen this
before
and very often members of the Trump
administration seemed to get out in
front of his ire they don't wait for him
to react instead we saw this when Trump
visited South Korea and there was talk
about members of his administration
trying to shield the USS John McCain
from view and it turns out Trump had
knew nothing about it
it was just members of his
administration trying to avoid a bad
photo op but with all of that said with
all that said is this like a president
level presidential ending level ending
scandal no that's that
silly I'll to talk about impeachment
over this sort of thing sure yeah and
Barack Obama's IRS targeted all of his
political opponents and he wasn't
impeached over that so there's that okay
in just a second we are going to get to
the Democratic side of the aisle where
Democrats are increasingly saying
extraordinarily radical things I feel
like a broken record on this but if the
Democrats stop being radical then I can
stop commenting on their radicalism
we'll get to that in just one second
first you're gonna have to go over to
Daley wire calm for $9.99 a month or $99
a year you can subscribe over its daily
wire you should because not only when
you spend 99 bucks years you get this
the very greatest and beverage vessels
but you're also helping us out there are
too many folks on the Left who want to
silence all dissent you've seen this in
everything from the comedy world to the
political world to the business world
well you can help protect the commentary
that you enjoy by going over to daily
wire comm and subscribing there right
now for 99 bucks a year or $9.99 a month
we really do appreciate where the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
you know you do have to wonder at this
point when you look at both parties
whether any of them are going to have a
really strong affirmative agenda to push
come 2020 it is like president Trump's
basic pitch is border and economy and
that's a pitch and it's a pretty good
pitch as long as the economy doesn't
downturn but what exactly are the
Democrats going to pitch in terms of
policy the answer is nothing you can see
why they're focusing in on the most
Picayune scandals in the trump
administration and blowing them up too
magnificent proportions because if
they're forced to talk about policy it's
really ugly and for the Republicans you
can see why they're focused in on the
socialism of the Democrats because
honestly except for a generic tax cut
that any Republicans probably would have
passed and except for enshrining judges
which is good but pretty much any
Republican Congress would have done that
I would assume neither party is is like
I see why so many Americans are
disenchanted with politics it's become
sort of this rooting war but you look at
both parties you're like what exactly is
the vision they're presenting I
understand why the other guy sucks I
just don't understand why you're so
wonderful is I think the pitch at this
point is why more and more people young
people particularly are identifying as
independence now you'd imagine that if
Democrats had an ounce of vision that
they should be cleaning up in this
environment and if President Trump were
able to contain himself he should be
cleaning up in this environment the man
has 3.7 percent unemployment rate but it
seems like neither side can clean up in
this environment because Trump is too
focused in on his own egotistical
silliness --is about the NOAA or
whatever is the latest tweet storm of
the day and Democrats meanwhile are too
focused in on their socialistic vision
for the United States and and running
down the United States is a terrible
awful no good very bad place example he
saw Bernie Sanders and Kamala Harris
both said incredibly radical things over
the last 24 hours
about the United States criminal justice
system so here's Bernie Sanders at a
rally talking about the American
criminal justice system I hope that all
of you know that the criminal justice
system in this country is completely
broken and is racist really the entire
system is racist is that where we're
going with this okay so it's broken and
it's racist
what is his evidence that it's broken
and that it's racist well presumably a
disproportion
number of people of minority descent are
in prison but we don't arrest people
based on their ethnicity we arrest them
based on the crime they committed so if
Bernie Sanders wants to identify the
people who should he wants let out of
jail any time now
Bernie any time you want to point to the
people who are wrongly in prison and are
innocent then I'm waiting on it but if
the idea is that the entire system is
inherently corrupt and endemically
corrupt you're going to need to prove
that to me by pointing out who are the
innocent people who are being rounded up
on the streets and then thrown in prison
this has become unfortunately a talking
point among Democrats this is it this is
why people are disenchanted with
politics politics right now is not about
solutions it's not about helping people
it's about just yelling at the wind and
Democrats right now are yelling at the
wind louder than Trump I objected in
2016 when President Trump yelled at the
wind and suggested the job loss in a lot
of dying Rust Belt towns was was was the
responsibility of free trade and
government policy and all the rest of it
I thought that that was economically
foolhardy I didn't think that it was
correct
I don't like blaming vague forces in the
universe for specific problems that are
generally the result of free market
forces so I didn't like when Trump to
that but on the Democratic side you know
what I really hate
the counterproductive nature of their
treatment of law enforcement
so Kamala Harris who is desperately
running for president she's the most
desperate can't there they're three
desperate candidates in this race right
now beta O'Rourke is desperate Kamala
Harris is desperate and Cory Booker is
desperate Cory Booker is always
desperate for attention beta O'Rourke is
desperate because he thought he was
gonna be the front-runner at this point
and Kamala Harris is desperate because
for a brief glimpse of Prime
she had popped up into that top ranking
now she has receded she did an interview
over the last 24 hours
it with the editor of salon on police
and listen to her Greenlight's
this take on police which is such a hot
take I mean this is a scorching
white-hot take it's insane we shouldn't
have to acknowledge that trauma because
like they paid the Vita and we live in
these places like police officers have
historically not that have an
accountable
because they protect and serve the rich
and then they just have rats and take up
space in poor communities I don't see
any type of big shift happening with the
one term because it's like a cultural
thing right okay so why doesn't she push
back there she's a former prosecutor
she knows the police in California why
isn't she pushing back when that person
says that the that the police just
harass and take up space in poor
communities the reality is that if you
actually wish to improve the lives of
people in poor communities black or
white you need more police presence not
less police presence why because who's
going to invest in a community where the
crime rates are high where your property
is not secure who's going to invest in a
community where there is no tax base
okay and the tax base doesn't exist
because if you can get your kids out of
that community then you move to the
suburbs who's going to do that the
single greatest factor that indicates up
upper income mobility in an area is the
safety in that area protection of
property rights protection of human
rights in a particular area that is what
is going to provide the preconditions
for growth in a particular area and you
have Bernie Sanders and Komal Harris
railing against the very forces you need
to ensure law and order in poor
low-income and disproportionately
minority areas okay the fact is that
these these high crime areas require
more police but Democrats aren't
interested in solving the problem
they're interested in pandering we have
a politics of pandering right now and it
is completely ugly and it is completely
terrible and I don't care whether we're
talking about pandering to the
president's ego or whether we're talking
about pandering to particular radicals
in politics by ripping on the very
people who are putting their own bodies
and lives in harm's way
we're not wonderful pay in order to
protect communities like if you think
the police officers are generally
signing up because the benefits are
fantastic and I would suggest you don't
know many police officers the this
constant rip by Democrats on the
solution to problems is supremely
irritating supremely irritating the
Democrat radicalism is the reason why
they haven't run away with this thing
already in president Trump's ego problem
is the reason why he hasn't run away
with this thing already
speaking of democratic radicalism long
piece in The New York Times today about
Bernie Sanders it's called Bernie
Sanders went to Canada and a dream of
medicare-for-all flourished
there's nothing I love better than a a
sophomoric sick of Fanta Kragh dick Ulis
piece from the New York Times about how
Bernie Sanders learned from the
Canadians about universal health care
says decades before Medicare for all
would propel his presidential campaigns
Mr Sanders his expedition to Ottawa
helped forge his determination to
transform the American healthcare system
his views burst onto the national
political scene during his 2016
presidential run when he championed a
single-payer program alongside many
other liberal policy ideas now as he
seeks the Democratic presidential
nomination a second time he has made
Medicare for all the most important
issue of this campaign and set the
agenda for the ideological discussion in
the primary
apparently the POE of Canada remains
strong for mr. Sanders Sanders described
how seeing the Canadian system up close
significantly shaped his own views on
health care he says it was kind of
mind-blowing to realize that the country
50 miles away from where I live that
people could go to a doctor we're out
whenever they wanted and not have to
take out their wallet that was a
profound lesson that I learned and then
he called the American system barbaric
apparently he learned all of this from
Canada but the truth is that his
original beliefs in health care actually
sound more Soviet than Canadian in
October 1976 when he was Liberty Union
candidate for governor he told the
Burlington Free Press that the delivery
of medical care was quote basically a
national problem and that he supported
public ownership of the drug companies
and placing doctor ease on placing
doctors on government salaries he said I
believe in socialized medicine and this
is being praised by the New York Times
as oh look what he learned from Canada
isn't that nice what he learned from
Canada by the way you make drug
companies owned by the federal
government and you can kiss innovation
goodbye and that's the one area where
America really does thrive we may lag
behind other countries in terms of cost
per capita but we are way ahead of other
countries when it comes to medical
innovation and medical patents over half
of medical patents happen in the United
States innovation lives here and by the
way if you're in Canada and you need an
immediate surgery
you know what you do you got on a plane
you come south of the border a Bernese
hit again they are the the radicalism of
the Democrats is is continuous and
terrible now in an environment where you
feel like he can't trust anybody really
where you feel like he can't trust the
right because the right is
busily defending whatever crazy is
happening at the White House today and
an environment where you feel like you
can't trust left because the left is
insanely radical and wants to destroy
the basic vision of the country who can
you trust well theoretically you would
say the media but the answer is
certainly not there the media continuing
to shower themselves in glory day in and
day out yesterday the New York Times
tweeted out a link about Mao Zedong on
the anniversary of his death the tweet
said this mount seitan died on this day
in 1976 the time said he began as an
obscure peasant and died one of
history's great revolutionary figures
I'm sure the times didn't say that he
also was responsible for the Great Leap
Forward ending in the deaths of 40
million people the New York Times then
had to delete the tweet they said we
deleted a previous tweet about Mao
Zedong
that lacked critical historical context
oh you mean you tweeted out that he was
a great revolutionary figure you know
who else is a great revolutionary figure
by your standard the New York Times
Hitler Stalin great revolutionary
figures also murdered tens of millions
of people so there's that but don't
worry guys
I trust our media our media are just
doing incredible incredible work on a
daily basis and that that our our media
who really are out there defending your
interests daily I see that they are also
doing this in the Hollywood media hey if
you ever worried that Hollywood may be
biased I have some evidence for you a
variety which is a trade newspaper here
in Los Angeles the only people who
subscribe to it are the agents who have
it on there their law their their glossy
glass tables for you to read while you
wait for your agent never to see you
Variety has a cover today called climate
in crisis the clock is ticking can
Hollywood muster its storytelling power
and influence to sound the alarm on
global warming because this is
Hollywood's job guys Hollywood job is to
cram down their vision of what should
happen on global warming on you isn't
that exciting so basically bottom line
there's nobody I would suggest in
politics that you can trust except you
which means that you're going to have to
assess all of these issues on your own
and that's tough that's tough but it's
good because the more independent you
are in assessing all of this the better
off you are going to be and the fact
right now is that everybody is too
invested in the partisan tribal warfare
to be honest about where things stand
as they stand right now and I think
we'll get an indicator of that tonight
in North Carolina frankly I think there
are a lot of people who are sort of
tenuously engaged in politics who will
show up to vote and we'll see how they
feel about things because in the end
that's going to decide where we go in
2020 not the contrasting vision of the
parties not even the talking points the
general feel of the thing and people I
think are generally frustrated I know
this is all a little bit vague I feel
like it's vague too but it's hard not to
feel frustration setting and even for me
and I watch this stuff on a daily basis
when we're fighting over whether the
National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration should redraw maps on the
one hand and whether we should fully
socialize the American healthcare system
on the other it's deeply frustrating
stuff okay meanwhile the other big news
of the day is that nearly every state is
now investigating Google over antitrust
and this to me is just another example
really another example of politicians
who are looking for something to do
and don't actually have the evidence to
support it a group of 50 Attorney
General's from 48 states the District of
Columbia and Puerto Rico unveiled a
major antitrust investigation of Google
on Monday sharply escalating the
regulatory scrutiny facing the tech
giant is according to CNN the probe will
focus on whether Google has harmed
competition and consumers looking at
least initially it's the company's
conduct in its search advertising and
other businesses although it may expand
from there now what exactly are they
investigating they're being
extraordinarily non-committal about that
very very opaque speaking to reporters
in front of the US Supreme Court on
Monday a group of 13 attorneys general
struck a bipartisan tone Karl Racine is
AG of the District of Columbia he said
it was an unusual setting for a group
that typically disagrees on issues
ranging from gun control to reproductive
rights he says but we are acting as one
today
Texas AG Ken Paxton said the
investigation will begin by looking at
Google's advertising and search
dominance but hinted that the scope of
the probe could widen significantly he
said the facts will lead where the facts
will lead well normally you have to sort
of identify the prospective crime before
you launch an investigation the police
can't just go to your house and be like
you know what we're investigating you
today like what are you investigating
you based on what well you seem kind of
suspicious if the police did that you
would rightly call them out for
selective prosecution
we have yet to hear from any of these
AG's what exactly Google is it wrong
that leads them to suspect that they're
in violation of antitrust law normally
and frankly I really don't think that
that AG's should be talking about who's
under investigation at all if you're
gonna conduct an investigation shouldn't
you have to come up with actual evidence
of how the investigation turned out
before you go public with this sort of
stuff we're living in a dangerous time
where big government actors have an
interest in attacking big business or
working with them alternatively and it's
all politically driven it's not
consistent in any way it's not that
government actors are opposed to big
business it depends is big business
shoveling money in their pockets or not
case in point Elizabeth Warren so it
turns out that Elizabeth Warren who's
been spending a lot of time lately
talking about how she will never take
big money it turns out she took a lot of
big money and then just dumped it into
her presidential campaign according to
the New York Times on the highest floor
of the tallest building in Boston
senator Elizabeth Warren was busy
collecting big checks from some of the
city's politically connected insiders it
was April 2018 miss Warren up for
re-election was it a breakfast
fundraiser hosted for her by John
Connors one of the old guard power
brokers of Massachusetts soon after
Warren was in Manhattan doing the same
there'd be trips to Hollywood and
Silicon Valley Martha's Vineyard in
Philadelphia all with fund raisers on
the agenda she collected campaign funds
at the private home of at least one
California mega donor and was hosted by
another in Florida
she held finance events until two weeks
before her all but assured reelection
last November then early this year
Warren made a bold bet that would
delight the left she announced she was
quitting the big money circuit in the
2020 presidential primary the open
secret however is that it was the
big-money fundraising through 2018 that
made her prominent she transferred ten
point four million bucks in leftover
funds from that 2018 Senate campaign to
underwrite her 2020 run in other words
she took a bunch of big donor money put
it in her Senate race transferred it
over to her presidential race and then
said you know what i'm anti big money
now man is our political class broken in
deep and abiding ways holy moley okay
time for some things I like and then
some things that I hate so things that I
like today Mary Lane is a reporter on
European issues with the Wall Street
Journal she has an excellent book called
Hitler's last hostages that is out today
it is all about the treatment of art
under
the Nazi regime about how art dealers
basically did
Hitler's bidding but made sure Hitler
had this whole take on art that modern
art was was truly terrible and deviant
and degrading and he wanted it destroyed
so the art dealers basically did his
bidding except they stocked up all the
modern art in their back room and
confiscated it from people at the behest
of the Nazis and then they headed out
until later and Mary traces the history
of art in Hitler's Germany and beyond
and how our dealers never gave the art
back it really is a fascinating story of
how history plays into modern politics
well worth the read Hitler's last
hostages marries a terrific reporter
Hitler's last hostages go check it out
over at Amazon today ok time for a quick
thing that I hate so I've noticed that
the left is gleeful over the impending
divorce of Todd Palin from Sarah Palin
and this I find somewhat astonishing I'm
looking up the articles on this divorce
this prospective divorce right now it's
been reported by CBS News by people calm
by CNN by salon by the Boston Globe
basically every major outlet has now
reported on the prospective divorce of
Sarah Palin and Todd Palin according to
CBS News former Alaska governor husband
apparently files for divorce citing
impossible to live together documents
filed an Anchorage Superior Court last
week do not include the full names of
Palin or her husband Todd Mitchell Palin
instead the filing only uses the
initials for their full names SLP and
TMP according to the Anchorage Daily
News the filing reportedly includes the
date that the couple got married and the
birth of their 11 year old son trig it
asks for joint custody of the boy the
other Palin children there four of them
are all adults by now so they have five
children together any time you see a
couple with children divorce that's a
tragic situation I will just point out
that the media's coverage of Sarah and
Todd Palin it is absolutely not
comparable to Ilhan Omar's perspective
divorce okay so ill Hannah Mars is
hitting Congress person who's
extraordinarily extraordinarily public
right now and the amount of media
coverage and the media reaction to Ilhan
Omar who by the way may have engaged in
campaign malfeasance
with regard to her funding of her
alleged lover
and that media coverage is nowhere near
the level of media coverage that you're
seeing for Sarah and Todd Palin Sarah
Palin has not been politically relevant
since 2008-2009 just to show you once
again the level of ire that the left has
for the right and particularly in the
media by the way if you never search
Twitter Twitter is a garbage site filled
with garbage people and if you ever go
to Twitter and check out things like
Sarah Palin and divorce you will see how
vile the left is how they how excited
they are about something like this and
I'm not excited that Ilhan Omar and her
husband appear to be getting divorce
they have three young children that is a
very bad thing nor should anybody on the
Left be excited when something bad
happens to a couple just because they
happen not to like the politics of the
couple alrighty we'll be back here later
today with two additional hours of
content or we'll see you here tomorrow
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo why douse key
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
joe biden's lead in early primary States
collapses overnight what will happen to
the electability argument on the
Democratic frontrunner then speaking of
Democratic presidential candidates Tulsi
Gabbard goes woke on a couple of issues
and thanks to the New York Times the
dumbest article on the Internet today
check it out on the Michael Dole show